Spencer Pratt just did what Spencer does
calling out his hills new beginning
co-star Caitlin Carter for supposedly
being with Miley Cyrus long before the
world knew I have no issues with anyone
let's rewind on Monday night's episode
of the hit MTV show Caitlin got all
worked up during a chat with Ashley
Waller and Whitney Port I'm hearing
people who are talking about me and
Brody and are personally saying that we
have an open relationship what does she
mean by that
relationship
yeah you heard that right polyamorous
Kaitlyn wasn't too happy about all the
gossip surrounding her then marriage to
Brody Jenner
that's not her business you know we just
like we like when Brody and I first
worked together we were young we were
crazy we were like you know basically
just trying to have the time of our
lives so we did a lot of things in our
relationships that you know I certainly
wouldn't say I regret but the level of
gossip that I feel happens in the group
it just makes me angry now Spencer's
giving his two cents on the situation in
a new interview with cosmopolitan they
need to calm down
quote it's tough for me to listen to
Kaitlyn complain about people talking
about her allegedly open relationship
with Brody when we know she had a thing
going with Miley she already had
something going on with her when these
scenes were filming maybe not physically
but definitely emotionally oh damn he
went there I think I can handle it
of course Spencer's referring to Miley
Cyrus whom Kaitlyn was spotted smooching
on an Italian vacation in August after
Kaitlyn and Brody split and Miley and
Liam Hemsworth split it's a little
strange sure they have seemingly been
together ever since
Kaitlyn was even backstage with Miley
leading up to her MTV VMA performance
but if you thought Spencer was done
there
you're sorely mistaken he went on to
sympathize with Miley's ex adding quote
I would love to know liam hemsworth
thoughts on Caitlyn's recent displays of
common decency you know what I call
common decency getting it on at your
Italian villa and not in front of the
paparazzi oh snap and the burns just
keep coming quote maybe you shouldn't
have gone on television it's called a
reality show hon and the reality is that
Brody's been talking about your sex life
on his podcast for years you were a
nightmare you don't think that's like
the rudest thing you could say you know
I hate when you say stuff like that
of course fans of the reality show
watched Brody and Kaitlyn's marital
issues play out on screen I came home to
a psychopath yelling and screaming at me
because I came home at a certain time
was it nerve-racking to be married and
putting that on my on TV because reality
TV in the past is up and great for
relationships in general it can be very
trying like it helped us it not helped
us but it brought us closer together
because it was kind of like us against
the world in moments when filming the
show sure so you get other people
chiming in another reality couple bites
the dust when are we gonna learn people
love and TV does not mix unless you're
Spencer and Heidi of course et will be
here to keep you up to date on all the
wild things Spencer says so make sure to
keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Hallie Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]